let's begin as we rarely do
in cincinnati and no this isn't about
their uniform that was leaked on sunday
although they should be happy we were
talking about the bengals on a slow
sunday in march that never has happened
in my recollection of the past 50 years
of following football now we're talking
about a franchise quarterback a true
franchise quarterback that they drafted
last year first overall joe burrow here
is duke tobin
talking about the plan for building
around the quarterback whose acl is
still in the process of being rehabbed
to 100 percent
when i look at our team i i'm excited i
i think we've got one of the
the premier best young quarterbacks in
the game and and we're going to do
everything we can to build around him
and give him the opportunity to really
shine and show what he can do and so
it's going to start with him
absolutely it's going to start with him
look it worked out well for the bengals
all those shireen
i've said this a few times recently and
bengals fans get upset about this
they could have taken what the dolphins
were offering they could have gone to
number five they could have drafted
justin herbert plus all the extra stuff
and they'd be in a better spot now than
they than they are but
joe burrows the real deal as well they
have to find a way to keep him healthy
and that begins with investing money and
draft picks in improving the offensive
line so he has time to set up and throw
that's how the injury happened for as
much as he runs the injury happened
because the pocket collapsed and he got
hit low and that was the end of his
season
yeah that's exactly right mike they need
offensive lineman they need them bad and
they need receivers frankly aj green's
gone we know and
you know he didn't have a good year
anyway so he needs improved weapons and
he needs an improved offensive line and
that doesn't mean just using that fifth
overall draft pick on an offensive
lineman or a receiver it means going out
in free agency and that was joe burrow's
big thing before the bengals drafted him
is are you going to build a competitive
team around me we heard him say that
over and over and they did last season
they went out and in free agency and and
did some things at free agency that
improved them overall they need to do
more they still need more people around
him to make him a better quarterback and
they have the sixth most cast face right
now mike they need to spend that money
and they need to draft wisely and this
will be a good team in the future
one thing the bengals do far more often
than the opposite they trade down they
don't trade up they trade down in the
draft and they may have an opportunity
with that fifth pick depending upon
who's left at quarterback and the
thinking is that trevor lawrence and
zach wilson will be on one two then
comes the mack jones pick if jones is on
the board at five a great chance for the
bengals to take a step back pick up some
picks do what they didn't do last year
in sliding down and addressing more of
their needs more lottery tickets more
players more people around joe burrow
and it's not going to be easy for them
we went back and forth last year and i
think you were team afc north i was team
nfc west as to which division was better
top to bottom
you could say going into 2021 if
borough's healthy the afc north is the
best division top to bottom and it may
be between the bengals and the steelers
to see who's in third place who's in
fourth place
yeah and you look at the quarterbacks in
that division mike with roethlisberger
and of course lamar jackson who won the
mvp award a couple years ago and baker
mayfield and this is a really good
division and i'm with you i think it's
probably the west right now but we don't
know how that's going to play out and
what's going to happen with russell
wilson and all those sorts of things so
they've got to get good they've got to
get better than what they were with more
talent around joe burrow if they're
going to contend in that division any
time in the next couple years because
it's a really good division with really
good teams so you need more players
around joe burl and frankly mike we
don't know how that acl is going to
affect him either you know normally it
takes players a couple years that second
year after the acl is normally better
than the first year after the acl and
he's going to be right on the edge of
getting back for the start of the season
so we'll see what kind of year he has
but to me this is a building year for
the bengals they just need to build on
what they did last year take another
step i thought they took a step take
another step this year i don't see them
as a playoff team certainly this year
but they have a chance to take another
step and let him get back and get that
acl right
in a weird sort of way
if the acl isn't 100
maybe it forces him
to stay within the pocket more often to
stay within himself to get rid of the
ball faster make decisions faster make
his reads faster and not be
so i don't want to say reckless but more
often than not he was on the wrong side
of reckless when it comes to the
pounding he took and he's not a big
thick guy and i talked to him a couple
of times about the hits he takes he
takes plenty of them and he's fearless
in that regard maybe if he has mobility
that is limited in any way as he
recovers from the torn acl he just gets
rid of the ball faster makes decisions
faster and positions himself better to
avoid this kind of injury in the future
because he clearly needs to do that it's
not sustainable to take the pounding
that he took last year and i think we're
also caught up in how well he was
playing
you know you don't want to wag your
finger at a guy right out of the gates
who is amazing and astounding us with
his overall physical feats but
look we say about jimmy garoppolo all
the time and i think it's fair to say
about joe burrow you have an obligation
to the team to stay healthy and that
means avoid hits it's basic science the
more hits you take the greater the
likelihood you're going to get injured
so reduce the number of hits reduce the
chance of getting injured that's what he
needs to learn from what happened last
year
yeah that's exactly right mike that
maybe this teaches him more to stay in
the pocket with that acl especially
early in the season and he's capable of
doing that it's not like this guy needs
to get outside the pocket to be
successful i mean we know he can stay in
the pocket and be successful we saw it
at lsu we saw it last season it would
have been real interesting mike if he
had stayed healthy all the way through
because halfway through the season we
were talking about him as probably
offensive rookie of the year and then
justin herbert just took off but i would
have liked to have seen him stay healthy
the whole year long and see how that
offensive rookie of the year race would
have come down to the wire because i
think it would have i think joe burrow
would have stayed in that race and the
bengals probably would have won a couple
at least a couple more games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports